couple of things crossed my desk this
week that reminded me that I think the
way we're all about to drive is going to
change in the next few years one of them
was a notice from the city of Lafayette
in Indiana that said that they were
working with the University Purdue on a
kind of centralized control for traffic
that would be able to see all of the
speeds of cars going on magnetic plates
on the ground and red lights and all the
red light cameras and then adjust things
from a central post to make traffic move
more smoothly another one was a notice
from Ann Arbor where they're about to
embark on a test to let cars talk to
each other three thousand of them are
going to be embedded with sensors that
can tell each other where the cars are
and how fast they're going this is all
part of letting cars learn to drive
themselves of course but it used to be
called intelligent vehicle highway
systems when I first started covering it
and back then I thought it was a
terrible idea they built a test track in
San Diego actually that was all censored
up and had cameras and motion sensor
stuff like that and and the computers
that read all that information we're
going to tell the cars on them on the
road how to drive it's a terrible idea
right you centralize this thing as soon
as it breaks you have an accident 80
cars going 90 miles an hour platooned
into a Road train or something and then
the city gets sued they'd never build
one again but of course what the Google
self-driving car thing kind of starts to
solve Sebastian thrown in his AI
research at Stanford starts to solve is
letting the intelligence reside in the
car right the car itself knows how to
drive now what's interesting about that
it's not that the car is smart but the
collective of cars are smart because
they're going to talk to each other the
cars are going to tell each other where
to drive how fast ago and that means
that they're going to be behaving is
what's called a collective they're going
to be engaging in the same behaviors as
a school of fish or a flock of birds
there are some really smart researchers
looking into what those behaviors are
kind of me and cousin or another one in
dirt helping who are trying to
understand the numbers behind flocking
behavior but one of the things that
happens in almost every case is that you
get from very simple basic principles
emergent properties right the behaviors
start to come out in ways that nobody
expected now cars are a two dimensional
case because they don't go up and down
not a three dimensional case like a
school official flock of birds but
principles do seem to hold now what does
this mean when all the cars on the five
between San Francisco and LA are all
talking to each other instead of having
the people in them driving well when a
predator swims through a school of fish
for example there's a sort of
characteristic the worls of fish that
emerge as they try to get away from the
shark so I kind of wonder what counts as
a predator when you have a school of
cars swimming down the road now they
don't all the same destination like the
flock of birds does but that's okay
because when they're all platoon
together they essentially act the same
way so like is the guy in the Ferrari go
180 miles an hour who's got the auto
drive turned off is he the the predator
is he the shark am I in my little Jetta
the minnow trying to get away this
doesn't sit that well with me I have to
admit I'm a ninjalino and I know this is
not the greenest way to think about the
world but I kind of have my identity
wrapped up in my car a little bit I sort
of think of cars as freedom and driving
as evidence that I am independent and
have power over my environment I know
that that's not how we're supposed to
think about things anymore but I can't
really help it so I feel a little bit
weird about the idea that that symbol of
my independence is now going to be
subsumed into a Borg like collective as
we travel around the city or get on the
highway still on the other hand I
suppose it's better than me in that guy
in a Ferrari